okay so here we are this is eating your
feet my name is nikki my best friend
adam has challenged me to make a giant
bowl of ramen based off of a viral video
i'm excited i love ramen i've never made
it before but how hard can it be oh my
god that really is large it's noodles
ramen broth a mountain of bean sprouts
and surrounded by fried chicken that's
mostly bean sprouts he barely even got
to the ramen he didn't finish it also
here to help me today she's very good at
everything that i'm not good at my
friend
i'm making ramen okay so i have to make
a broth i have to cook noodles i have to
blanch bean sprouts and i need to make
chicken what's different about japanese
fried chicken we cook with potato starch
instead of flour oh all right so i'm
just gonna give this a shot see you
later
i've never made ramen broth i know it
can be quite difficult but i think i'm
gonna find like an easier version of it
oh this isn't japanese i don't know what
it says i think we're just gonna stick
to the show ramen
i also don't think i made fried chicken
on like my own before i need ramen
noodles and i need a lot of bean sprouts
okay i can do this for suresies all
right i got a bunch of stuff and this
cow he's pretty cute
and he's full of jelly a cow bank
it's like jello shots but for kids i
have to marinate my chicken this recipe
is per three
i'm gonna triple this chicken recipe
that i have i'm just gonna start grating
some garlic this is ginger i knew that
i'm just cutting the skin off of the
ginger and then i'm gonna grate it and i
need roughly
six stains
this grater's too small grating it might
not be the best idea i just decided to
chop up the ginger instead my fingers
are gonna smell so spicy it's for a
marinade so it doesn't need to be super
crazy pants next i'm gonna do roughly
the same amount of garlic i'm just
crushing it so that it breaks open and
tossing them in how does this one look
weird i'm gonna use it
[Music]
okay i think that's good enough i need
nine tablespoons of soy sauce nine oh
ten oh well
it's just completely spaced out forgot
my apron six tablespoons of sake oh
sesame oil
oh that was hard three tablespoons of
sesame oil
oh god well sugar mmm
looks good i hope this is enough because
i got a lot of chicken coming in oh
chicken gloves there we go oh my god
this is a lot of chicken good gravy okay
this is enough marinade that looks
pretty good all right i'm gonna let this
sit in the fridge for about an hour and
then we'll come back and i'll add potato
starch and we'll be ready to fry it all
up here's the big bowl i got i think it
is large enough it's bigger than my face
but also i have um these ice cream
sandwiches that i can't put in the
freezer anymore so i'm going to eat them
oh
this is really tasty yeah broth the
recipe calls for regular soy sauce and
then a light soy sauce and then salt it
doesn't make a lot of sense but i'm just
gonna do it there's two tablespoons of
soy sauce of both kinds i'm gonna times
that by four so that's half a cup of soy
sauce
this is not efficient
oh this one's even worse okay there's
that this is a lot of salt why are we
cooking soy sauce and the rest of it is
chicken stock this is a lot i don't know
if it's all gonna fit in that bowl this
feels very
salty
yeah it tastes like chicken bones in
water i'm just gonna add this to here it
looks like a beef broth
it's not terrible
pretty good yeah it is very salty yeah
this is a little salty so i'm gonna add
some water to it that's tasty broth is
done i still have to do noodles the
beans i think we should do chicken next
looks good it's been marinating for a
while now pot of oil for frying i've
never done this before
so i need a cup and a half of potato
flour this is what's gonna make it
crispy this is weird i need to dredge
these a little bit better so i'm gonna
get a bowl and put the rest of my potato
starch in there to make sure that these
are well covered i'm going to do one
test chicken
[Music]
is this supposed to look like that
there's like this bunch of like white
stuff on top so i don't think we need to
dredge it like this so i'm going to put
these ones in here and just kind of keep
it at this saucy texture and see what
happens whoo
bubble city hi
[Music]
we're just getting started with some
fried chicken yeah that looks great so
that's way better so i definitely don't
need to be dredging them extra and i'm
supposed to like put them back in and do
a double fry to make them extra crispy
but they look really good they smell
really good so i'm just gonna keep going
oh they smell so good we can smell the
ginger and the soy and the garlic all
right that's the last of it i still have
to double fry it but i'm gonna wait and
make sure i have hopefully 1.2 kilograms
1.4 kilograms
so these two are just extras this is my
second fry it's at a slightly higher
temperature it's going to be a for short
shorter amount of time it'll just crisp
it up a little bit more uh
my empire is not on anymore
i ran out of gas
wait on fire
oh god these have been it for so long oh
man these are very crispy it's fine it's
fine
look at all this chicken
oh yeah
oh whoa i'm gonna cut up the chicken i'm
gonna leave them pretty large one point
two five that's a lot of chicken and
they're spares i'm gonna get that hot
from our beans this is what i'm gonna
cook my noodles in and here's my ramen
how much do i need 800 grams of noodles
good lord
this is my broth it's been sitting back
here but i'm taking it off now because i
think it's warm enough i'm gonna get my
pasta water heated up this is 2.27
kilograms so i'm just gonna go with this
and then pile it high and if i need more
i'll make more not what this is for
this so beany this is gonna take forever
well look at this ridiculous bowl of
beans goodbye bean water this is label
we got our beans we got our chicken we
have our noodles and my broth
oh yeah that's really salty i think i'm
gonna water it down a little bit more
because that is pretty salty that's
better all right so i'm just gonna start
assembling we'll go broth first that
feels good i'm gonna pop the noodles in
here we go
looking pretty good
i don't think that the watery chewy is
it boiled no it's just very hot you have
to cook the noodle in a boiling water
love it i think these noodles are cooked
come on
oh they're all gooey this is not
appetizing looking okay now we bean
sprouted this is what they do they make
a bean sprout mountain i am very excited
about this chicken though this is a lot
of work just putting it together not
even just like attempting to eat it wow
this is like the perfect amount for this
bowl
all right i'm going to go get erie and
the only thing left to do is eat all of
this i hope you're hungry i am but i
cannot finish this we're going to do it
together okay okay at the restaurant if
you finish this in 20 minutes get your
name on the wall and they pay you how
much fifty thousand yen fifty thousand
yen eats five hundred dollars let's see
how far we get in 20 minutes go
go wow
yeah
what recipe tasty.com
yes
there's no way we can finish by
ourselves you know i think it's already
watered down it's not salty oh look
noodles no
i think i understand why that guy was
sweating oh wow yeah the broth is like
nothing
because there's a big spout i don't
think the three of us could even get
through this you want to bring people in
yeah are you guys busy a bunch of us are
eating giant ramen
yes get in here i made this
thank you we're 10 minutes we're halfway
keep going here have a straw for broth
where's the salt the bean sprouts soaked
it all up all right
there's almost been 20 minutes we have
like two minutes left i think there's
like 10 of us here but there's still a
bowl full of sprouts and noodles so i
don't know how anyone does this i think
i did a pretty good job i made a broth
from scratch made noodles i made three
pounds of bean sprouts and one and a
half kilos of fried chicken which is my
first time being french i was really
tasty our time is up we did not win
tastes like a soy flavored water
but chicken was great
oh yes
[Music]